oh I'm I mean I'm pro-life but um I
heard an interesting argument the other
day that made me think
um it was like by Destiny where he it
was something with like brain function
so I will say like you know I could be
more educated on the science so that's
that's actually why she came on my show
the other day and I just thought it'd be
interesting to like learn what they had
to say
and it changed recently what your
opinion changed no I'm still pro-life
I'm still pro-life but it was just an
interesting argument where I was like
um I'd have to find the video but it was
by Destiny he was doing like pro-life
pro-choice and Destiny's such a good
debater and I was just like I've never
thought about it that way
but no I I'm still I wouldn't say I
changed my mind I'm still pro-life
can I ask you a question uh so both of
you guys are pro-life
um I didn't catch your name as uh Ruth
Ruth Ruth
um so for example my auntie um she had
twins when they were born but one of the
twin
um was in critical condition and then
when he was finally born he was on life
support
the doctor told my auntie
he's going to suffer the rest of his
life being on life support like feeding
him through a tube and whatnot what do
you want to do and it was a very
difficult decision and she just had to
let one of the twins die
and
I know like you might say that's wrong
but I think there are certain
situations you can allow abortion great
um
that if they're suffering I mean I don't
I don't I wouldn't say yes for like oops
I wouldn't say yes for like the uh
euthanasia where it's like an adult
dying because you're pretty much at the
end and all you have to do is just fight
through the end and then you know you
can state that you didn't commit suicide
kind of thing in a in a sense
um but then again if it's if it's a baby
being born and it's gonna suffer for the
entire life
I think uh that is one other condition
that I would stand with abortion um
or letting the baby die so that's it so
so you're pro-life with like a couple
exceptions
basically yeah and I also want to get
your view on what would you do if you're
a mother and you've just had a child and
that child is going to suffer for the
rest of its life with um like it's sick
yeah um your feeding tube
um whatever so what would you do I
actually had a cousin that was in that
situation
um
I mean I would just do everything I
could to keep him alive and if he died
he died like I mean
I just think I'd have a hard time like
killing killing my kid
um personally
but no I had a cousin and he was only
supposed to live till he was three and
he lived till he was like 12.
um but it wasn't a good quality of life
it was actually really hard to watch so
um I could see why it would be like hard
for someone to go through my other
cousin as well um from my mom's side
this time uh she's she was born as well
as a twin funny enough and she was
paralyzed from birth or actually no she
was okay but the doctor or the hospital
didn't give her enough oxygen when she
was born so she started um her brain
didn't send the correct signals to her
body so she was just paralyzed now um
she suffers in other words in other ways
so she's growing up seeing her brother
uh move in and walk in running playing
football and she's always going to be on
a wheelchair do you know what I mean and
like I don't know how to explain this to
you but she really hates life you know
there's only a few things in life that
make her happy Maybe music seeing her
family food but then most of the time
she's just suffering because she can see
the world and she can see what she
doesn't have
and then again
like this can be avoided at the very
early stages
and uh not like obviously I'm happy to
have her in my life and I love her as my
cousin but you know I can see her
suffering yeah and the family as well
well I just think doctors can be wrong
and that's like where I would have a
hard time like if they say they'll have
this disease and they might not yeah
yeah there's so many so many situations
where that's happened the Rain Man uh
where where they've yeah doctors have
diagnosed something in the womb and the
mothers have refused all they said the
baby's gonna live this long and the
mothers have refused abortion and their
children are healthy and fine you know
there's doctors get it wrong
so what would you guys do then if you're
in that situation so I think Paul gave
me a chance what would you do if your
daughter or son was born and then you
have to make a decision whether they
should live or not the same thing I
could never kill my child okay
um I just I would hope and pray
that
my child got better I felt like oh sorry
no no go ahead are you finished yeah no
I was gonna say I feel like happiness is
also inside a lot of people get it
confused where they're watching the
outside too much and they're requiring
all this temporary happiness like oh
when I get money I'll be happy or when
this or when I do this but actually it's
just inside if we search for happiness
inside we we will be happy but a lot of
people compare themselves to other
people's lives and things like that but
I do like I would never understand
someone who's obviously disabled or
severely
um unwell you know it's it's quite
difficult but again we don't know what
the afterlife is no one knows but if
they're alive here today
maybe there'll be another sort of lie
for them no one actually knows because
none of us has died so you know but we
just don't know but that's a good point
yeah
yeah I was just gonna say I've got two
things I just want to go back to what
Cass said earlier on about having the
right support
um in place
um because you work in mental health as
you mentioned I did yeah oh you did
before okay
um and I think it's similar with the
abortion issue and
um for a woman that finds out that she's
pregnant
um I think a lot of it is based on being
properly informed about the process
you're going through
um so that you can come to a um informed
decision I feel like
um from my experience
um having an abortion when I was 19 I
wasn't properly informed like
abortion is something that is classified
as a medical procedure
and with most medical procedures that
you do have and I've had a few
um in my lifetime
um nothing severe but you are informed
about what the procedure is going to be
you are informed about
um you've shown images of what you're
going to have done and I feel like
abortion is sidelined oh yeah it's not
you don't you're not properly informed
now so for me my experience I came out
the other side and there was a lot of
mental trauma
um and there was a lot of healing there
was a lot of healing process and the
support I think is very important if you
do decide to have an abortion
um as it was in my case and I didn't
feel like I had that at that time and
just to go back to what ruby was saying
um about your your family situation
there's a guy I can't remember his name
and he's literally he was born without
no limbs like he has no arms no legs and
he was actually
um he's on YouTube he's a big YouTuber
and I mean his life is phenomenal on
it's going back again where where what
does happiness look like how do we
define happiness he's in this world and
he's impacting this world and like Leaps
and Bounds and he was born that way he
did mention that when he was I think it
was 10 or 12 that he wanted to commit
suicide I can't remember what he stated
what got him over that hurdle but he's
still here today and he's living he's
living a
fulfilled life do you know what I mean
so I think as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform it if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible